[Music]
in the southern part of Croatia in the
peninsula of paljah Zak there is a
winemaker that does things a little
differently I mean by Odin a president
vino is promoter that's right this
winery ages their wine seventy-five feet
beneath the sea surface after growing up
around many traditional winemakers Edie
had an idea to combine his two favorite
pastimes scuba diving and drinking wine
so he decided to try an aged wine in the
sea well do just a movie no oh
linen won4t Kotaku poly any more modern
to avoid any leaks in these ancient
storage jars Eadie uses a glass bottle
to keep the wine in and saltwater out he
uses custom-made cages that line the
seafloor to hold the wine in place Volta
spray o bonito Warren ideal twist
chapter soon Adnan a primadonna
Graziano da da da da good in any cotton
Adira allo Bettina Jesse Provera
Visakhapatnam stag Donna sister Anja the
say we destroy a cocoon estate
[Music]
temperatura McCoy Sweden as of the
javanese Sonoma Vina Eastern aversions
partnership WT silly party Sheena
Jelena factor Oscar means LM Odadjian
uno to appear conclusion of in AB and CD
it's this silence that differentiates
his unique underwater wine from the
patent sat response team Padma token
Wadena ceraadi
bada so Medtronic a primitive a
dishonest or adivasis in astronomy
geometry Tzu Kui ka Raja PO drama
silvano Tetsu airplane achieve organism
mutation on a novena we know dobby i
ragazzi a pony oak whose negative in on
what's normal or pakalana me llamo was
editor as acrostic Alcala de queijo
bottom business purpose not is
familiarity signature of i premed
Yachvili chorus
[Music]
bioluminescence is the scintillating
effect of a living thing emitting light
and in a small coastal town in central
Japan one glowing creature is also a
delicacy
[Music]
trauma Bay is around 4000 feet deep one
of the deepest bays in all of Japan and
home to one of the only commonly edible
bioluminescent species in the world
música de todas Jota Ricardo Yoshida's
regional on Andromeda masks adore
paladinous in particular Colorado
Firefly squid fishing isn't a normal
fishing job they have to fish in the
dead of night bioluminescence sea
creatures prefer the dark depths of the
ocean but the Firefly squid lights of
the shores when they spawn making them
easier to catch hungry chose their
meeting you are one of them manage their
Jim be awesome
Sulekha la sangre near the only possible
way to be the hero jean-bob hero hiding
desk at all irony Sam that was our papa
you only have our Papa hiding us where
is all that squid going well to places
like capillo rocky a small Japanese
restaurant an American economist co2 ah
and Johan do you know itemizes totti
cano Cesario fossils only a variety
owner so you had skills to the massive
trauma can cut our economy you know our
rotary catamaran is named Hamato c'mon
go amok they all see you don't know
audio for car like this could they
resist every muscle chef Iraqis menu
includes multiple variants of Firefly
squid from salted to grilled boiled to
sashimi all of them delicious and most
importantly fresh ass out here
your daughter stays on the mosquitoes
I feel we are overusing the resources of
our planet we want to expand the
possibilities of Agriculture in an
environment where it wasn't Bob that you
could actually grow plants we think that
that can really change the outlook for
the future Nemo's garden is an
alternative agriculture project where
we're trying to find a way to grow
plants underwater in underwater
greenhouses we have grown between 50 and
60 different species basil different
kinds of salads goji soy sprouts medical
herbs harvesting the plants is actually
very simple we cut it just like we would
do on land and then we wrap it in two
reusable plastic containers and we just
close it up and we pick it up on the
surface nice and comfortable the main
challenges of growing plants under water
are has never been done it's all new
initially the learning curve was very
steep every operation has to be done
scuba diving
that is a challenge on itself the main
advantages are the protection from
outside elements we are underwater
nothing can get to us no pests means no
chemicals needed and of course no hail
no storms the temperature stability that
we have inside the water which is a lot
more stable than outside plus the higher
pressure on the water apparently makes
our plants grow faster and stronger and
with higher contents of essential oils
the water that we use for the plants is
mostly from evaporation of the surface
of the salt water once it's evaporated
it condenses back into rain we basically
create fresh water automatically that we
don't need to consume any energy for
we know that climate change and and the
future of demography is headed towards a
way where we will be overusing the
resources of our planet
I hope the Nemo's garden is a way to use
those resources in a very respectful way
and balanced way the whole culture for
the project is to expand the
possibilities of agriculture in a world
that is covered more than 70% in water
it simply makes sense to us
[Music]
seaweed is a common ingredient in
Japanese cuisine but there's a unique
type growing in the Pacific Ocean ma
hobo - Thomas okay now Jessica my
Saturday night - she's joining Joan
among this seventy miles of the coast of
mainland Japan is the small island of
Okinawa home to one of the most unusual
farming methods in the world what about
you me god
I'm not going to bite you ho hold on
there kiddo mr. Oshiro comes from a
seafaring family and today he is one of
the farmers growing mozuku a special
seaweed only grown in these waters
fishermen look at Lejeune in my graph
mostly Yokosuka next a monster claw well
as you hasn't it each fall a web of nets
are laced with mozuku seedlings on land
then mr. Oshiro and his son lay the nuts
in rows in the shallow water this
ingenious system allows the mozuku to
grow sustainably by not creating
additional waste and when the time is
right it is harvested with two boats and
their giant vacuum
[Music]
[Music]
Sam be a comedian Oh Eddy aha potestas
Los Alamos nuclear hypervisor day they
take it to Ankara Tony Santiago Mo Kio
instead it's mock colonist the day's
harvest is then taken to his factory
where it's cleaned weighed and processed
then it's off to the markets to sell his
underwater treasure
Sam crow activist mozuku is in high
demand
it's packed with nutrients so many
people eat it for a health boost but
that wasn't always the case
mozuku ah Lucas you had a burrito
sunless skin Acosta was you know no
kidding girl Maya Cara
Yo no moon Cala high-pitched a plan
actually they tax on top of your leptin
wha not that kind of psycho circus
unique musical hero you can all say
Okinawa's tomas in recent years mr.
Oshiro has seen a change in the ocean so
the future of his mozuku is uncertain
cos a cos i see Amin Amin in Agoura take
some cocoa Saiga jubilation Alito most
Gidget Agra you O'Connor
oh yeah recognize Terry curry salt and I
know they're against a nominal system
order to a cancerous ecology throughout
Podesta Mon Ami no can't yoga yoga route
oh it's gonna work you're emotional
so now can you taste it you know maybe
to attack America toga wo motte ikou I
got a mother
Nikolai by Megan okay to need cash
tonight OH - OH -
despite the challenges mr. Oshiro stead
ocation proves this work is more than
just a day job for him it's about
maintaining a family tradition and
passing on his father's respect for the
sea so notice notice on Carnegie Roman
and a sushi congregate a culture today
so know each other
you don't akuto what is your modernist
surreal matter do Berlusconi yep it's
very logical
hello - no business only see the
criticisms now what I selected a war it
happen I see you know sedan it shall
delight in Canada
[Music]
you